carolina panthers a team that was in the
super bowl three years ago and they were
six and two last season chris sims
before they ran into that buzz saw in
pittsburgh and the wheels came off by
the way this pro football talk live nbc
sports radio nbcsn hello to our friends
in the uk enjoying the program on sky
sports we're getting right into it this
hour with a look at the carolina
panthers we've looked at every team no
one gets short shrift and it's last but
not least we still have one more to do
later this hour but we're getting them
all in before memorial day and the
panthers a team that that if cam newton
is healthy
they can be very very good i remember
when the odds first came out for uh the
chances to win the division and each
division had its breakdown the panthers
an attractive choice to me because if
newton is healthy christian mccaffrey
coming into his own the defense is
always going to be good with ron rivera
there it's it all it all hinges
on the shoulder of cam newton yeah it
definitely does or at least that offense
and some of the issues they have there i
mean carolina yeah you know at base
value is a playoff caliber football team
you know yeah the wheels fell off last
year with that pittsburgh steelers game
then they lost two games in subsequent
weeks subsequent weeks excuse me with a
member of the detroit lions game cam
newton misses the wide open two-point
conversion they outplayed the seattle
seahawks at home and russell wilson made
some magic late in the late in the game
to get them back in it and win a miracle
football game and everything fell apart
out of the fact like you said that cam
newton's shoulder issues were there and
they couldn't throw the ball down the
field but the offensive line i think the
first thing you have to talk about with
carolina because that's been the weak
spot i do think they've gone somewhere
to correct that this off season you know
by signing a matt paradise at center
from the denver broncos one of the
better centers in football that's going
to be great resigned daryl williams uh
who was a pro bowl type tackle uh
they're gonna move him to guard they got
a guide taylor moton who was a second
round pick last year he's gonna be
tackled got greg little this year uh in
the second round from ole miss who i
thought was first round worthy as an
offensive tackle so i think at the very
base level they've made improvements to
that o-line to protect cam newton and to
continue to be a balanced offense so
that's good uh so i like that aspect of
their football team and i expect cam
newton to be more protective this year
than maybe we've seen in years past
but ultimately he's got to protect him
he doesn't say this about all the
quarterbacks with a history of getting
injured and especially when just a
couple of weeks ago as cam newton was
turning 30 he said he's he's too old to
change his playing style well if you
don't change your playing style you're
going to continue to have these off
season shoulder surgeries ankle
surgeries because even though he is an
incredibly impressive physical specimen
it's still the same
bones and muscles and ligaments and
tendons that everyone else has and you
will get injured the more hits you take
from nfl caliber defensive players no
matter how big you are it's one of the
reasons why he doesn't draw as many
flags remember that was a thing a few
years ago he doesn't get flagged for
when he's hit by defensive players he
doesn't get the roughing the pass or
penalty called for him it's he looks
indestructible right and it looks like
guys bounce off of him well the reality
is they don't and that's gonna be the
key and and use christian mccaffrey you
know i said when they drafted him two
years ago if you're gonna make this guy
the eighth overall pick chris you better
use him and they used him last year and
i think they even have more in store for
christian mccaffrey this year and he can
really come into his own and be a guy
that takes a lot of heat off of cam
newton and helps loosen up the passing
game in carolina yeah
no question he's got a special skill set
i mean run game pass game and he's more
of a bell cow running back than maybe we
all give him credit for as far as
running between the tackles does a good
job of not getting you know crushed in
those car crash type hits he showed he's
durable and he can you know last the
long haul of the nfl season so yeah
continue to get plays and and give
christian mccaffrey the ball dj moore
their first round pick from the 2018
draft he had some phenomenal moments
last year he's a special specimen can he
continue to grow into being a complete
wide receiver you know second round pick
from three drafts ago in the 2017 draft
curtis samuel he's a guy that's battled
injury at the wide receiver position
they need those young guys to really
show themselves this year they can't
just be oh this week they're great then
we don't hear from them for two weeks
they got to be consistent part of the
offense weekend and week out i look at
that and you know going back to what you
said about cam newton too about
adjusting his style of play you know i
agree with you one of the things i'll
say about cam newton too you know
ultimately he heard his shoulder in the
pocket last year standing there too long
and i would say that was one thing i
would say was a problem for cam newton
throughout his career last year i
actually saw improvements with it with
north turner i think god in his brain
hey you don't always have to look for
the big play down the field it's okay to
throw the short pass every now and then
get it out of your hand and
i think cam newton was going in the
right direction with that last year but
still has to be careful about just
standing in the pocket all day long
thinking he can take hits and never be
affected by it
from six and two all the way to seven
and nine last year they really did fall
apart there were questions about whether
or not ron rivera would be back i think
david tepper the owner of that team who
just celebrated the one year anniversary
as the owner of the team did the right
thing did the smart thing rivera has
been a coach of the year rivera has
taken the team to a super bowl and i
think he's a very stabilizing presence a
very calming influence that keeps that
team focused he tried his damn just
after that blowout on a thursday night
in pittsburgh to keep the team focused
it just wasn't to be and as cam newton
had more and more trouble throwing the
ball down the field chris that's when it
became conspicuous i mean how look we
talk about this all the time with the
chiefs patrick mahomes can throw the
ball anywhere so what does that mean you
have to defend the whole field if the
quarterback can't throw the ball deep
you can put all 11 guys into a 30-yard
window and it makes it a hell of a lot
harder
to move the ball a consistent basis when
you don't stretch out the defense and
open things up underneath yeah no i
agreed with that and that's why you know
with cam newton's style play and the
shoulder injury i do worry about the
backup quarterback situation in carolina
you know
at least when they had derrick anderson
he could run the down the field
aggressive big arm plays that cam newton
can i don't know if there's anybody on
the roster than carolina that can do
that now let alone they lose all the
movement stuff they do with cam newton
with the group of backup quarterbacks
they have because they're not movement
type of guys whether it's fake the speed
sweeps or the read option or the
quarterback design run so their offense
has to change with their backup
quarterback there's no doubt about that
so that's a little concerning
other thing we do have to hit on mike
hey getting brian burns in the first
first round you know the the dn for for
carol for caroline out of florida state
uh phenomenal athlete that was one issue
if i had to say with the carolina
panthers over the last year or two i'd
look at their team and go
other than luke keikley okay you got
kawan short at defensive tackle who
needs to pick up his game he did not
have a great last year and he's being
paid like one of the best d tackles in
football and he was a little
underwhelming this year or last year i
should say so i expect him to be back
but they didn't have a difference maker
that come off the edge and really create
havoc and i'm i'm hoping that brian
burns can be that guy for them
phenomenal freak athlete who's a speed
rusher off the edge and they've needed
that in carolina
and they're going to need leaders on
defense this year with thomas davis gone
julius pepper's retired you need
somebody to be the heart and soul of
that defense and and who knows maybe
we're going to see the pendulum swing a
little bit toward the offense this year
i'm amazed by christian mccaffrey's
stats and i think of one of the guys
that we could peg as potentially ready
to climb to superstar status this year
you look at what mccaffrey did last
season he went from 197 touches as a
rookie to 326 in 2018 he averaged five
yards per carry over a thousand yards
rushing 867 yards receiving almost 2 000
yards from scrimmage and it's almost
like we didn't notice i know right we
noticed great performances but there
wasn't that week to week oh christian
mccaffrey is one of the best running
backs in football hey folks christian
mccaffrey is one of the best running
backs in football and this could be the
year that he flat out explodes so get
ready for it i'm not saying it's going
to happen but we saw the evidence last
year that it's moving in that direction
and if he improves last year this year
like he did last year that this guy
could be potentially in i don't want to
say mvp conversation because we know
that's a quarterback award yeah but this
guy could end up being in offensive
player of the year conversation i i hear
that you know and added to what you said
yes he's a phenomenal football player
and you know like i said a few minutes
ago i was surprised that he could take
the wear and tear and the bell cow type
you know carries between the tackles uh
and to your point i mean i think what
can further along his statistical
prowess this year and everything that
you know we talk about for being
offensive player of the year
if cam newton's shoulder is healthy and
they can actually throw the ball down
the field to where they back defenses
off and a curtis you know curtis samuel
and a dj moore do start to assert
themselves a wide receiver and now
secondaries have to go whoa we have to
worry about this aspect of their offense
too yeah christian mccaffrey can kind of
at least hide a little bit or they can't
always game plan just for him and let
alone if greg olsen can stay healthy
down the middle there's plenty here for
this carolina team to be a playoff
football team and really be you know a
major player in the nfc when i look at
it at least on paper at this point of
the year
hey chris and christian mccaffrey can't
hide in the gym we've all seen that
photo of him my goodness christian
mccaffrey you know that when you rip the
sleeves off the hoodie all the way up
past the deltoids yeah that's usually
right that's why that's his shoulder's
fine we have doubts about cam newton's
shoulder i think christie mccaffrey's
shoulders are just fine so it tells me
he's putting on that extra coat of armor
he understands what's going to be needed
for him to take the next step you can't
be slight of build and be an effective
running back in the nfl and there's
nothing slight of build about christian
mccaffrey so what do we expect out of
the panthers this year chris is this a
team that could win the nfc south i do
think potentially they are a team that
can win the nfc south if you made me
pick right now okay no i don't think
they're gonna be
nfc south champions uh i think if you
made me peg where carolina ends up i'm
going to say they make the playoffs this
year i will say that i think they're
a ten and six type of football team who
has capabilities of healthy to make a
run in the nfc because of their defense
and the style of play with cam newton on
offense
yeah vegas has the over under win total
for the carolina panthers at eight so
those of you who are in the jurisdiction
where that sort of activity is legal i
think
our advice would be take the over for
the carolinas
this year and and i i i just think that
you know every year there's a team that
catches fire early and holds it the
whole year and it was the panthers three
years ago right and we we know that cam
newton's got the skill to do it and
christian mccaffrey all due respect to
the running backs at the time christian
mccaffrey is better than any running
backs they've had since ron rivera has
been the head coach that they they could
be that team that just that did start
your rack think of that week well you
got the rams coming cross country to
start the season in a short week game
against the buccaneers
if the panthers can build some momentum
and some confidence and if newton is
healthy they could roll through this
schedule this is not a daunting slate of
games outside the division especially
since they get the rams at home to start
the season the panthers are very tough
to beat at home this is a team that's
got the patriots number for crying out
loud exactly so i i think the panthers
let's not sleep on the carolina panthers
folks uh they may have something uh up
their sleeves for all of us or or not
sleeves if it's christian mccaffrey you
pick them to go nfc south champs like i
gotta formulate how i think the nfc
south is gonna go out i still don't know
there it's such a good division it's so
competitive i don't know yeah what do
you got right now yes i think this i i
just i think it's gonna be very hard for
the saints to sustain after two very
heartbreaking postseason exits and signs
that drew brees is starting down that
inevitable slide to not being a
franchise quarterback any longer i i
think the pen
newton's the big concern he hasn't
thrown yet chris at least last year
andrew luck was throwing the high school
football in late may and early june
newton hasn't thrown and i feel like
that question is going to continue to
hover over the team until he does throw
and until he takes some hits and gets up
and is able to keep throwing yeah agreed
we got to see that that's some one of
the things that uh we all are gonna feel
a lot more comfortable about the status
of the carolina panthers once we see cam
newton throwing a ball in training camp
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports